I think if you told me a rapist I just
made my sandwich I don't feel deep you
know
now the nature of people they're having
a bad day you don't know do you
they can spit in it I can lay on the
floor I could do anything I'm relying on
the taste of a great product to win the
public over already well if they've got
misgivings I'm on hand to put them
straight was made minutes ago around the
corner that starts actually made in the
prison right ladies first
no they're not they're not pedophiles I
can guarantee that no armed robbers
burgers hopefully I've managed to
reassure them I Mexican rap certainly
shouldn't bother people it's fresh it
tastes nice really good yeah yeah
there's no razor blades in it or
anything no one's a particular bothered
that made by prisoners quite happy the
fact as long as they're not made by
pedos trendy marketing types were a
relatively easy sell but what will the
hard-working man on the street think
that would break through the ideas
getting these guys out of the cell and
into a kitchen working always like a rep
as well fella how does it make you feel
that we're made by prisoners nice to see
we got 12
unfortunately down to nine what time I
get back we'll probably be down to five
Oh guys chance come over come over the
bad news everything didn't go yeah oh
yeah fine okay
the good news is we made for 270 yeah
yeah the public seem to have the stomach
for prison made lunches I think they
could be the future of the business can
you imagine if we had ten boxes out
there would come back with two now after
three grand a day
twenty-one grand a week it's just under
a million pound a year that's not now
you're talking no no seriously listen I
want to take this thing to a complete
different scale yeah so I can sign as my
critics from the governor to the SOS to
every officer could you do more yeah no
okay well done so farm two quid that's
just under a pony age right over my dead
body